so today I'm gonna talk to you about how
to turn an oh moment into a quickly
growing product market fit company I
hope you've all heard about get around
but if you haven't we're gonna be giving
out off fifty dollars driving credit to
anyone who hasn't tried us so you'll get
to experience it soon I hope all right
so we started get around back in the day
at singularity University in 2009 if you
haven't heard about it it's a phenomenal
school I got the great opportunity to be
in the inaugural class with 40 other
students and it's all focused about
taking accelerating technology and
applying it to humanity's greatest
challenges so back at singularity my
co-founder Sam was also accepted so we
packed her bags we left Canada and we
knew that we were in for big things
coming out to Silicon Valley this was
just post recession and so it was a
really cool time to come out here and
then pretty much on the first day we met
Larry Page who gave us this big
challenge he said okay Jessica your your
mission here is to come up with an idea
that can positively impact a billion
people in ten years and so we really
took that ten to the nine challenge to
heart you know when Larry Page says go
you really go hard and so we did we
jumped in and we decided to focus on the
global transportation industry we felt
that this was one of the most broken
problems that we're facing today and the
stats are really astounding so there's a
billion cars on the planet that sit idle
22 hours a day so that's 22 billion
idle car hours it's a pretty much a
necessity everyone wants or wants access
to a car but really in this day you
shouldn't need to own one so we really
saw an opportunity to kind of leap
towards the self-driving car and to kind
of propel what we helped to foster which
was the sharing economy so with this
problem you know twenty two billion car
hours idle every day
second-biggest household expense and
cars that are just available for use oh
big idea this is a game changer and so
we decided to call it car overpopulation
essentially there's too many cars on the
planet so if you can get car speeds more
efficiently you can take cars off the
road in fact each share car takes ten
cars off the road you could you know
stop cars from being in landfills you
can stop the emissions needed for
manufacturing and really it seemed like
an amazing problem to work on and so we
took kind of a long-term mission around
this we knew it would take us a while to
kind of tackle it but get around as some
of you know and love today is really a
simple concept it's a marketplace for
sharing cars so you have cars that are
instantly available from your phone by
the hour by the day you can unlock it
and you can drive but when we started
with get around most people that we told
about the idea they said that's crazy
it'll never work sounds cool but there's
gonna be too many hurdles don't take
that on but of course we were really
committed we got this 10 to the 9
challenge and so we kind of dove in and
you know we we knew we were gonna have a
lot of hurdles to overcome so I'm gonna
talk to you guys about that in a minute
but at first you know we wanted to get
proof of concept fast even though this
was a huge idea we wanted to get it to
work on a micro level and so we actually
took advantage of the fact that we had
about 200 students on campus with us we
had the singularity University and the
international space university together
at Moffett Field and so we thought ok
well let's try to see if we can get a
handful of cars and a handful of people
that'll share them because really you
know when you start you have this great
idea the first thing you have to do is
you have to go and talk to people and
see if people like it or people don't
like it people think it's dumb or the
people would use it and so we went
around and a lot of people said that's
crazy why would I share my car with a
stranger but like any sound you know
founder you just ignore that and you
keep going right
so we did and luckily what we did with
this small beta or super small alpha is
that we saw that people were willing to
share so let me give you the stats
around this we had just 10 cars which
you know a small number but 10 people
really said I'll share my car with
strangers and we had about a hundred
people sharing over a one-month period
so with that we felt like we had enough
to go off of that there was something
here and to give you the background it
was a very manual process so nothing
like get around today which is all
powered by the app and the hardware
technology was completely manual so you
had to basically text an owner meet up
exchange the peas return the keys at the
end of the trip but still people loved
they thought I'm stuck I don't have a
car and this is really making my life
better and so we thought we're we
thought we're really onto something so
I'm gonna sum this up in lesson number
one and I don't know if anyone else has
done this but what I was hoping to do in
the time we have left is with our three
lessons I wanted to say them all
together so we can kind of lock it in so
let's go to the next lesson I'll tell
you what it is I'll explain it and then
we can kind of say it together and we'll
lead you through it okay lesson number
one is start small launch big so we just
talked about this it's super important
to get something working on a
micro-level before you try to scale it
this applies to a ton of different
scenarios you know you don't want if you
start in one market you don't want to
expand to more markets before you really
have it working you know you want to
really invest in a big launch and if the
first launch doesn't work try again and
try again and try to do it in a big way
so you know find the right venue hire
the PR firm you know do whatever you
need to get a big launch but really have
a good story have users that you know
just a handful of people that can speak
to a positive experience so we really
felt like this was true with us our
story was that we started small at
singularity and then we worked really
hard to get insurance hardware
technology and our iPhone app and
everything together and we ended up
launching at TechCrunch Disrupt about a
year and a half later so we had
do a lot of work to do that and then we
want it and we got thousands of users
and over 5,000 people that said they
would share their car overnight so that
was a huge win for us because everyone
said this is a crazy concept it's that
we're gonna work and then you you launch
with this concept of hyper credibility
or super credibility where you it's
super buttoned up you know every
question someone would ask you have an
answer to you have you know top
investors or you have top academics on
your side kind of supporting it and so
when you watch big then that's where you
can get your kind of you kind of get off
the ground you hit the ground running
and then you kind of get propelled
really quickly one thing to say about
that is that if you start at a really
high point then you're almost always
likely to go down so it's really hard to
keep going up if you start really high
and so that's a another fun story for
another time but lots more lessons out
of there all right so lesson number one
is start small launch big let's say it
all together start small launch big
thanks guys great job I'm really really
sorry about my voice but we're doing it
so alright let's move on to the next
story so I already alluded to this a
little bit about some of the huge
hurdles we had to overcome I can't tell
you how much hustle we had to put into
all of these areas and I'm just glad we
did it because there was a lot of fun so
we we have to overcome three major
hurdles just to even get to market so
the first one was insurance the second
one was legislation and the third one
was hardware technology in a way a lot
of this was us taking a long term vision
on the market opportunity and the
basically wanting to make sure we were
launching aboveboard and not in a gray
area since it's such a cutting edge
disruptive idea so the major thing I
want to talk about here is how hard we
had to work to get an insurance product
so essentially you you all got the idea
for get around you have people sharing
cars this is never existed before it's
such a basic idea why can't you share
your car when you're not using it but
the insurance industry doesn't see it
that way
so basically you want insurance
you do what anyone would do call an
insurance company say this is what I
need I'm willing to pay for it I've
money and then they say no so not only
do they say no they say I have no idea
what you're talking about and this is
never gonna happen and we thought we
were set up you know we worked it from
every angle we networked we got in with
the CC of the big insurance companies we
looked at commercial insurance companies
we looked at little tiny insurance
companies and so we cold-called we've
sent like packages in the mail we did
pitches we did really really pound at
the payment on this one and you know of
course you're getting commercial brokers
and that broker didn't seem to work out
so getting a new one and at the end of
the day we probably were cold called
like 200 insurance companies trying to
get insurance and probably you know
around the hundred and seven to the
second rejection and we had any formal
packages responding so people liked us
enough people liked us enough to say I
want to talk to you again in 12 months
so that was a positive indicator but we
still couldn't even launch her product
because we want to have insurance so
people feel comfortable and this is all
legit so basically one one kind of way
we ended up getting it done was to
actually pass legislation to make to
clarify how the insurance would work so
basically it's a simple concept we ended
up passing what's called a B 1871 in
California and then in a number of other
states so when you're driving your car
is an owner that's your insurance when
you're renting it out to get around
that's get around since we're the
insurance companies were all concerned
was well what happens when there's an
accident during a get around rental
who's gonna cover that and we said well
you guys that's what we're paying you
for and they said well that's not clear
so basically we passed this law then
they couldn't ignore us anymore then
they really felt like hey these
Getaround guys are doing something
they're passing laws and so then we were
able to get a big partnership with
Berkshire Hathaway and soon
we've had a lot of other insurers
approached us so that was one major
hurdle one other thing I want to mention
is that we also develop hardware
technology in-house so that was a big
investment early on and it's ended up
paying off a ton because that's what's
enable us to do a completely on-demand
completely seamless product it took us a
few years to develop and you know we we
tested off-the-shelf products as well
and that's that was a big hurdle but
it's been it's now a big asset so one
thing I want to say about this lesson is
to focus and keep fighting so if you
really believe in something don't give
up no matter what and you know just keep
pushing really hard keep trying
different angles I'm sure a lot of you
guys have been in a similar situation in
your career where you didn't know how
you could get something done for me
personally getting this insurance was a
big win forget around for me personally
it was an interesting learning where you
realize one thing that we're told and we
all know which is think outside the box
so this legislation was a really strong
example of that where you know we've
been working as hard as we could trying
everything we could try and then it just
so happened because I have a political
background where it was just like okay
well why don't we go on this angle and
it happened to just make all the
difference so don't forget to think
outside the box if you know you're
really stuck on a problem and yeah so
the lesson here is to focus and keep
fighting because that really paid off
for us and you know we focus on a few
key hurdles and then of course we focus
on other hurdles later on keep fighting
for what you believe in
so let's lock this one in together guys
focus and keep fighting awesome thanks
all right so moving on to the a little
bit more of our story already told you
guys how we launched at a crunch disrupt
this was an amazing honor and a ton of
fun especially to go from this crazy
idea to you know very hot startup that a
lot of people believed in I think we
were the first company ever to win both
the grand prize on the audience choice
award just kind of fun
I think the story here is actually about
how we have this big vision for enabling
people everywhere to share cars and we
actually had the vision very very early
on that it was gonna be a mobile first
product and that you know you could
unlock the car from your phone and then
when we when we launched we decided okay
well we want this to be kind of possible
anywhere so we actually decided to start
without requiring the hardware and early
on we thought it was very important to
allow owners to specifically accept and
requests people they wanted to share
with and specific times they wanted to
share so early on we made the product
very owner owner focused with a lot of
owner control and the reason this lesson
is all about failing fast and listing is
that we weren't achieving the objectives
we weren't we weren't getting the growth
we wanted we weren't you know we were
hearing feedback that people loved it
but they couldn't get a car as often as
they wanted and I think there's there's
definitely the gold standard now and
transportation around you know having a
car just pick you up and now with get
around you can just get a car and
whenever and wherever you need it but
early on it wasn't that easy so we kind
of had a realization that we weren't
achieving our vision forget around in
terms of it being extremely convenient
and easy and so we we kind of we after
launch attack crunch disrupt we raise
our series a and we were kind of off to
the races rolling out to new markets
developing products hiring people but
then we still had this kind of lurking
feeling that maybe we didn't have
product market fit maybe it wasn't quite
there it was working enough but was it
really the right thing to scale with and
so there's a second slide to this here
so when we announced our Series A we
decided to roll out a new product called
getaway which was kind of an answer to
figure out how can we get more reliable
supply out there so for you any of you
guys in the audience doing marketplaces
you know all about supply and demand
supply is always a growth
it's harder to get typically so if you
figure out how to get more supply it's
very beneficial to the healthiness of
the marketplace so yeah getaway was we
basically wanted to figure out how can
we make the experience better and one
thing we tried was to manage cars for
people so a lot of people are
approaching us and saying hey I love
what you're doing I live in you know
Nevada and I'm going abroad for a year
can I give you guys my car I'd love for
it to be part of your you know car
sharing revolution and so we thought for
a little while we were turning those
people away and we said no we got to be
focused on the business we're running
here but then we realized that this
might be a good opportunity to test
different products features we have in
mind and so we announced this and a lot
more people with similar stories you
know living abroad working abroad
traveling came to us and so we ended up
having a pretty cool fleet of 50 cars
very quickly and we kind of we kind of
shut it off there we had lots more
people that wanted to give it to us we
also had people which is also a positive
indicator for any marketplace businesses
around in kind of power power users or
investors so we had a bunch of people
wanting to give us cars to manage that
they just counted us investment vehicles
literally investment vehicles so what's
cool here is it was really a learning
for where we wanted the product to go
and we started getting the type of
growth that we until this date hadn't
really even had only really heard of so
very quickly we got to 600 instant cars
and we had a million rental hours and
then we had we were booking a hundred
thousand hours a month and so this came
from taking the learnings from get away
and deciding to open it up to the
broader platform and eventually what
we've done today is we only allow the
on-demand option so the real story I
have to tell you here is about deciding
to kill certain products so we launched
getaway it worked really well but we
decided that
we didn't want to be in the business of
managing cars so we weren't you know we
didn't set out to become a rental car
operator where you know we had lots and
we had thousands of cars or tens of
thousands of cars or millions of cars
that were managing so we actually had to
we we ended up killing get away and
we've always been very open with our
community and so they they understood it
we had to develop a lot of product
features to set up for the on demand
model like screening users quicker and
having better calendar management and
having kind of all kinds of different
little mechanisms in the experience that
would make it possible but basically by
killing get away and then most recently
killing off requests it's been amazing
way to focus the product and also just
be able to sell an experience that
people want so previously people would
ask you know how does it work and when
you have three different product
experiences you know you can't get into
specifics but now how it works is
extremely easy and extremely simple but
you know in that in that change we we
shut down specific markets we had to
make a lot of changes and so over time
your strategy changes but I think the
most important thing is I should get
into the lesson side lesson number three
is to make bold choices so we've learned
a ton from this being bold has like
really carried us a long way being bold
enough to tasks get away even though it
was gonna cost us a lot of work and we
had to do a lot of things manually to
support it you know then killing it then
rolling out on demand to the whole
marketplace then convincing originally
when we rolled that out owners were used
to the control so they said hey I don't
know about this but we got 20 people who
said they try it and then on instant the
owners were making so much more money
that they were just screaming from the
rooftops like this is amazing get on
board I love it and so they became great
champions for kind of the new model and
eventually then you know then you just
say this is the only way and if you lose
10% of people then you just take that
loss because it's better for everyone
so yeah make bold choices let's lock it
in guys make bold choices all right so
get around today I was supposed to give
you a bit of an update at the beginning
but I'll just go into it all now so
here's some of our lovely team we are 80
people today we've raised over 40
million dollars from top investors we
are here in San Francisco in soma
growing a ton we have over a thousand
instant cars and we have 250,000 users
and we're growing expanding out to
various cities now so we're in the
mostly Bay Area we're in Portland we're
in Washington DC and we're launching a
few major East Coast markets this year
so getting excited about that we are
hiring so check out our jobs pages
you're interested or tweet at me and
talk to me and I hope you guys have
learned some interesting stuff from this
talk I like to try it and a little bit
early so we have more time for questions
okay so a couple questions actually
first curious if you've ever looked at
the aviation market in addition to cars
and second what all went into getting a
be 1871 past so a lot of people have
approached us to do different verticals
it was actually a focus kind of priority
to just focus on cars we thought the
opportunity is big enough and we you
know in the future we have big goals we
want to be global and you know be
available everywhere but we were focused
on cars so I know there are a couple a
VA ssin startups I don't know them off
the top of my head but not that many
people are doing it people are doing
boats basically I think new pilot in the
industry is in decline oh yeah yeah yeah
well they're big assets it's just for us
cars are can be you can use it more
frequently and it's basically there's a
lot more of them
so it's a more mass market opportunity I
think but yeah there's there are a
couple so what did you have to do yet to
get maybe 1871
so yeah we actually partnered with
incumbents in the industry in a sense
competitors to work on that we I mean
it's it's kind of a process but you just
kind of pitch people on the hill and
then you kind of work with someone to
write the law and then Lobby legislators
or not officially a lobbyist yeah good
questions Thanks
all right come on up guys we have a
little bit of time hi thank you for
talking to spite being sick I'm curious
how Getaround differs from other car
share platforms like car2go or Zipcar
yeah great question really great
question now like I said now that the
products streamlined I can answer that
very clearly
so basically get around is quite similar
in a way to those services and that you
can rent cars by the hour a day in
general we have a very broad variety of
cars we have a lot more locations we
hear that they're you know in someone's
building or on their block or in
someone's driveway so the the car
variety can vary quite well from
anywhere from Tesla's to out ER aids to
Priuses or Mini Coopers or pickup trucks
we also don't charge any membership fees
so you know it's we've lowered all the
barriers to trying the service and
entering it me personally when I came
out to the Bay Area I looked at the
signup fees and I thought huh I don't
know how long I'm gonna be here so I
never signed up so we want anyone who
comes to be able to try it because as
soon as you try card sharing your your
whole perspective around cars and car
ownership changes as well I think we're
a lot more scalable and it the the big
thing is the money goes to people who
are owned cars so it's really giving it
we obviously make a business out of it
too and we get a cut but the money goes
to helping your neighbors keep their
cars and you know do things they want to
be doing thank you thanks last question
just wanted to ask you quickly about
intellectual property and your
intellectual property strategy great
question like I said at the beginning we
kind of took a long-term view on the
opportunity
and we worked on passing or in the
political brain right now filing a lot
of patents in our early days and as well
as trademarks so luckily we have a
pretty tech savvy team that has done
that for both business patents and also
kind of the technical officer from the
hardware to the whole experience all
right thanks guys have a great day